thank you very much for those kind words
it's great to be here great to see a
good crowd and several friends in the
audience so I have challenged myself a
little bit in rather than giving my
standard talk I'm going to give you a
slightly different talk and also with
the different titles who have never
really taken on such a big challenge but
let's see how it goes so how can we make
progress to really make progress you
first need to really understand what
really are the goals without knowing
what the goals are you cannot make
progress towards those goals so I would
submit to you that psychiatry research
was by and large have three different
goals in mind
the vast majority 80% plus are
interested in establishing markers of a
disease this could be a genetic marker a
new imaging marker any kind of
biological measure that you can use to
validate your clinical concepts there's
a smaller group of people who really
understand the patient's experience and
would like to use neuroscience to
understand how a person is experiencing
a delusion a hallucination a panic
attack whatever it might be never very
different often I refer to this as the
typical British approach to psychiatry
because it's informed by a lot of
traditional psychopathology and the
smallest number of people but growing in
size in a piece you are several of those
people are in the room today have a
different take on this and say you have
to throw out number one and number two
we have to start all over again and
actually first understand the brain and
walk our way from the bottom up all the
way to the clinical phenotype I've also
given you a little quiz here because
these sweet people represent these three
different views and I will introduce
them one after the other so you can pick
your favorite candidate for position
number one that happens to be emil
kraepelin who pioneered the application
of diagnostic principles in psychiatry
he basically shaped what we still do in
psychiatry which is identifying disease
units in patients labeling them with
things like dementia praecox
now called schizophrenia or
manic-depressive illness now called
bipolar
the second person who was much more
interested in understanding the person's
individual suffering was organ boiler
who coined the term dementia praecox
into schizophrenia in tooth in 1911 the
person outside of this group the odd one
out was calvin aki who published a
textbook called principles of psychiatry
in 1900 interestingly never translated
into english and in this textbook he
lower challenged the status quo of
psychiatry and said you've got it all
wrong you will never end up with neural
markers of illness if you do not
understand the brain first also when I
was putting together the slide I was
getting a little bit concerned that
having a German accent being interested
in the neural basis of psychiatric
disorders and having facial here somehow
poor segregates so just read this quote
psychiatry is a young still developing
signs that must against sharp opposition
gradually achieve the position it
deserves according to a scientific and
practical importance there is no doubt
that it will achieve this position for
it has at its disposal the same weapons
which have served the other branches of
medicine so well clinical observation
mr. Osler they on the left the
microscope and experimentation so it's
against opposition it will achieve this
position but hasn't done it yet I mean
although it's a little bit antiquated it
could be said today but this goes back
to this sixth textbook of psychiatry
where crapola actually created the
paradigm the still major paradigm in
psychiatric research which is that three
different representations of a natural
disease unit can be studied we can be
clinicians and can be focused on
clinical features we can be
neuroanatomists waiting for the person
to die doing a pathological examination
and validate the clinical impressions or
we can be geneticists or epidemiologists
so whatever we would like to
those days and understand the etiology
but the most important assumption in
this research which still governs our
psychiatric research is that those three
clinical features the anatomy and the
etiology converge to validate the
disease units there is the fundamental
flaw of psychiatric research today
because it doesn't work or it hasn't
worked so far and we have to really
rethink how it could go better
despite that the American establishment
in the 1970s realized that they are not
making much progress relying on
psychodynamic lis infused vague
principles of reality distortion and
have to make progress particularly in
the area of schizophrenia with those
crippled Indian concepts so Busey and
Robbins both psychiatrists at Wash U
then changed the paradigm at least the
American paradigm had not been neuro
based nobody in American psychiatry at
that time in a powerful position
embraced neuroscience as a most
important principle to understand
psychiatric illness so they focused on
diagnostic validity and they outlined
five different phases so you start out
with clinical description then you
progress to laboratory studies then you
exclude diseases from each other based
on those biomarkers and then you do
follow-up meaning longer to long studies
and ultimately family studies to study
the heritability or genetics and by
applying those principle they concluded
and this more speculative than data
driven paper that you can separate two
very distinct groups of patients with
schizophrenia those with poor and those
with good prognosis so that's my prelude
into this topic I will now switch gears
and give you in about 40 minutes or so
the summary of my 20 plus years of
studying laboratory abnormalities in one
small region of the brain and then
return to the topic of how much progress
I have made personally or how much
progress we need to make as a field to
advance our understanding of psychiatric
illness so keep all of those
in mind as you now start looking at a
small region of the brain the temporal
lobe and particularly the hippocampus
you will you'll appreciate here that the
paragraph MP campbell gyrus basically
makes it impossible to appreciate the
full extent of the hippocampus but when
you carve a way out of the white matter
and cortex from the lateral convexity
you can see the anchors the body and the
tail of the hippocampus if you make a
cut through the mid body of the
hippocampus you see the typical t-shaped
amounts on formation corner Monas
subfields one two three and four and a
similar section can also be appreciated
on an MRI scan which is here used to
display a functional activation paradigm
so I will take you through three levels
of investigation starting out with a
large literature on hippocampal volume
changes in psychosis an emerging
circuitry model and also in abnormality
at the level of an individual's type of
neurons that gives rise to a activity
difference that we can measure with
neuroimaging so I told you that crap
Ellen was already talking about
schizophrenia before 1900 but it took
until 1985 before a researcher ever got
interested in the hippocampus now we
also know that the neuroscientists were
a little bit slow in picking up on the
importance of the hippocampus in general
but it took until 85 until bogus'
published a post-mortem study here you
see coronal sections two coronal
sections through a healthy brain and two
coronal sections through the page so the
brain of a patient with dementia praecox
because these brains were collected
before 1945 and they were still referred
to as dementia praecox and you can see a
pretty robust clumb hippocampal bar
anchors here don't be confused by the
white and the black this is a missile so
a myelin stain so the gray matter is
white and the white matter is black but
you can easily appreciate the remarkable
difference in volume and also the
concomitant enlargement of the lateral
ventricle here's the scatterplot from
this paper these are the hippocampal
volumes in the house
controls these and the patients which
resulted in a 31% volume difference
between the two samples this was the
original description of the now most
robust structural abnormality known in
schizophrenia which is hippocampal
volume difference this is just one of
the many meta analyses and reviews that
have been published on this topic it's a
pretty crude measure of displaying the
significant differences but you can see
that the hippocampus is consistently
involved to be smaller than in patients
in healthy subjects a much better way of
showing these data is from this
meta-analysis of 44 our Y studies for me
as a chair I always think about return
on investment but this refers to region
of interest study so you painstakingly
outline the shape of the hippocampus
rather than giving two freesurfer or
some other automated segmentation
program you actually focus on the
hippocampus and then you can see the
effect sizes for these volume
differences are 0.5 or higher which make
them for psychiatry very robust I want
to focus on this particular study
because it allows us to compare
different groups of patients with
schizophrenia at different stages of the
illness let's start with the left so the
gray and dark bar here show that
hippocampal volume and they're plotted
in contrast to the healthy control group
so this is about a 7 to 8% volume
difference in chronic patients with
schizophrenia meaning they have had the
illness for at least six months or
longer
this is first episode schizophrenia this
is within the first year or two of the
illness and schizophrenia form is the
important one here this is the precursor
of schizophrenia you have the illness
for at least a month but no not more
than six months more than 90% of those
patients ultimately ultimately progress
to schizophrenia so it's akin to maybe
mild cognitive impairment converting to
Alzheimer's disease and you can see here
that there is color Lee a gradient or
volume change over time with smaller not
significant changes making them more
significant as the
this progresses so that's going to be an
important aspect when I come back at the
end of my data presentation when we
actually start to do longitudinal
imaging studies of hippocampal structure
and hippocampal function so that
summarizes my review it's a rather
extensive literature but the take-home
message is that yes the hippocampus is
smaller in volume about six to eight
percent compared to a healthy match
control group if that is the case you
would like to of course know what really
drives this hippocampal volume
difference that we can now pick up with
even low resolution MRI scans so you
need to develop a circuitry model and
you need to understand the anatomy that
underlies this structural abnormality
givemea I will give you a 1-minute
working model of what the hippocampus
does for you they are experts in the
room so I hope you give me a break and
don't expect this to be for the
aficionados but just as a working model
multimodal information arrives at the
internal cortex and conveys the
information via two different pathways
indicated here in red as the direct
pathway and in blue as the indirect
pathway those two pathways convey
different information the information
that arrives with the direct pathway is
the online recording of sensory input it
basically allows you to have a running
tape that conveys this information into
the hippocampus in contrast information
that is arriving at the same neurons in
CA one but arrives yes who the try
synaptic pathway allows the hippocampus
to retrieve previously stored
information and it is the ability of
these individual tramble cells in CA 1
that allow those neurons to detect a
coincidence between those two different
inputs and depending on whether that is
a match or a mismatch this pyramidal
cell will then fire and we relay this
information to other parts of the
hippocampus and so the big column back
into the cortex so the model really if
it became the function although there
are several that the core means that the
hippocampus allows you to compare all
the new and to encode that information
into long-term memory
so now that we have this working model
we would like to know are any of those
regions of the hippocampus selectively
affected or any of those cells the
pyramidal cell or those different types
of local interneurons selectively
affected in schizophrenia to do that you
have to start out with a very
time-consuming stereo logical sampling
of the whole hippocampus to estimate not
only the volume of the hippocampus but
also the total neuron number of the
hippocampus so just for you to know we
have about 10 to 11 million neurons in
each of your two hippocampal compare
that to 10 to the power of 14 neurons or
so in the CNS so it's a very small
number but crucial for this encoding of
new information this is the third of
three studies that have used serological
sampling and none of them have found any
difference in the total number of
neurons in schizophrenia compared to
healthy controls this is a remarkable
difference compared to other
neuropsychiatric disorders that are also
associated with hippocampal volume
change most known of course are the
dementia slike Alzheimer's disease but
also epilepsy and several stroke
syndromes where the neurologist uses an
MRI to diagnose a patient based on
hippocampal volume change and that he
became a volume change is invariably
associated with loss of neurons
primarily pyramidal cells so that's not
the case in schizophrenia so we were
digging a little bit deeper this takes
me back many many years ago when I was
spending time at the microscope to plot
literally each and every neuron that I
was seeing another microscope this sea
of color-coded dots here blue for cr1
yellow for ca2 ca3 and red for CF or
represents a pyramidal cell and the
white larger dots indicate the inter
neurons the GABAergic cells and you can
see very easily that there is a
imbalance in much greater density of
pyramidal cells excitatory neurons
versus inhibitory neurons in fact the
ratio in the unit became verses ten to
one quite different from the cortex of
the thalamus way it's sweeter one and
that imbalance between excitation
inhibition seems to be crucial for the
hippocampus to do its online recording
and the constant matching of all tenue
also consumes a lot of energy and it's
the highest accumulation of mitochondria
in those inter neurons because they
tonically have to inhibit activity of
these pyramidal cells so once we knew
that it's not a simple loss of neurons
we were more interested in the different
subtypes of engine rooms this is a very
simplified scheme of all of the
different subtypes I've only listed four
different ones but they can be
distinguished based on the connections
that they are making so this would be an
EXO somatic connection this would be an
EXO dendritic connection they can also
be subdivided based on the proteins that
they are expressing many of those being
calcium binding proteins again they have
to be taking up a lot of calcium in the
repolarization so they express a high
level of calcium binding proteins so we
became interested in two different
subtypes of neurons the Powerman
positive cells which are inhibiting
either the soma itself or the axon
hillock and the somatostatin positive
cells which inhibit the dendrites and we
did this with gene expression we did
this with protein expression and this is
the last study which did a total neuron
number estimate based on the expression
and the serial sampling through the
whole hippocampus so this is a cut
through the c1 region which shows you
the stratum Orient's the pyramidal and
then rlm and this shows you the
expression of somatostatin positive
neurons and this the expression of
Palawan positive neurons when you plot
this out you can see a dramatic
reduction in the total number of those
two different classes of inter neurons
please take into consideration that
those two inter neurons make up less
than 3% of the total number of neurons
in the hippocampus so while we are
showing here a 40% reduction of those
inter neurons it would not come out in a
estimate of total neuron number as I
showed you earlier so you will only find
that by doing gene expression studies
where we could show the same or by doing
cell counting with protein expression so
I hope I have convinced you that for the
circuitry there seems to be a
preferential deficit of these inter
neurons have highlighted here the Pavao
and positive interneurons there are also
other ideas about changes in the
pyramidal cells but I would say that the
evidence right now points to a much
stronger effect with a decreased
expression of protein and genes and
potentially a loss of these power and
positive in some other statin positive
cells so that wraps up the second level
of investigation so the question then is
what does this mean really for the
properties of the hippocampus as it
guides behavior such as memory so in
this theoretical paper John Lisbon and
several other people who at that time
were working together with Joe Karl on
his Conti Center they were primarily
interested in this particular synapse
the NMDA receptors in the glutamatergic
axon collateral that feeds back to the
local inter neuron and keeps tonic
inhibition or so a tonic drive on this
fast biking inter neuron to then provide
the inhibition of the pyramidal cell and
the question arose then is this really a
deficit of the NMDA receptor the
so-called NMDA receptor hypofunction
model or a primary deficit in the
activity or the integrity of those
GABAergic fast-spiking inter neurons
that is not settled I'm not going to
show you the data today they are
emerging animal models that have probed
both of those questions by application
of for example ketamine or by the
strengthening of these GABAergic into
neurons both of those groups have found
evidence for their favored model which
is NMDA receptor hypofunction
or GABAergic deficit so I will not close
the chapter on that but the important
message is that this leads to an
imbalance of this firing of these very
large pyramidal cells indicated here in
this region c1 that are surrounded by
this inter neurons
so we've mapped out here just
schematically the somatostatin positive
neurons and the Pavillon positive cells
this is where the cell bodies are
located that's where their projections
go and so if you have a decreased
inhibition by these powerful and
positive cells you will get an over
excitation by axons that arrive from CSV
arriving and cu1 if that's the case you
would have pasta sized that the firing
pattern of those neurons is increased so
that moves me to the third level of
investigation if that is true then you
would like to use in vivo imaging
measures to ask the question can you
measure hippocampal hyperactivity in
humans so the original evidence comes
from this pet study that we did many
years ago where we looked at this
phenomenon which is the increase of
regional cerebral blood flow in a group
of healthy subjects when they're
engaging in two different tasks you can
ignore the baseline for now but those
two different tasks only differ in the
ability to accurately recall based on a
word stem q previously learned words for
healthy subjects the accuracy here was
barely above chance whereas the accuracy
for this condition was above 80% and
that remarkable difference in word stem
cued recall accuracy was entirely
related highly correlated to an increase
of regional super blood flow in the
hippocampus and no other region of the
brain that pattern of increased blood
flow in the context of increased recall
accuracy was completely lacking in
schizophrenia if there was one it was
going the opposite direction and tonic
lis there was a substantially greater
regional super blood flow throughout the
entire experiment not modulating blood
flow in the constraints as you would
expect of the working of the memory
paradigm so we followed that up with
several other experiments I'm just
showing you two of those today so this
is one of the most boring experience you
can imagine you put a person into the
scanner and you just look at the same
face for literally eighty seconds and
that's all they do
it's
is going to be presented over and over
again and in a healthy hippocampus but
also amygdala you actually see this
pattern of a controlled here in these
open boxes of a decreased bold signal
over time which we refer to as a pattern
of evacuation which does not occur in
patients with schizophrenia so because
of some uncertainties about the paradigm
we replicated this in a similar paradigm
now it's 120 seconds now we do two
different variations we not only have
repeated faces which was the original
paradigm but we also have novel faces
and we also do it for repeated and
different objects to really tease apart
the effect of novelty versus repetition
and also faces versus objects and this
is an interesting pattern that emerged
when we did this so this shows you the
difference between the two groups so
control greater than schizophrenia bold
signal change and ap campus and it's
true for both faces as well as objects
so this did not make a difference and
the healthy subject you still get this
previously shown habituation pattern for
the repeated faces or repeated objects
but you get the opposite pattern an
increased bold signal over time over
those 120 seconds for the novel faces
and that interaction was completely
lacking in the patients and that then
drove the between group difference and
that interaction have BQ ation to repeat
it and increased bold signal to novel
faces actually predicted the the
accuracy of the healthy subjects and
also the patients to remember words
outside of the scanner in a different
memory paradigm administered at the same
time indicating that this ability to
modulate hippocampal function the
ability to have beat you ate or to
increase to novel stimuli is related to
memory function let me switch gears and
move from the bold signal studies I've
given you just a selection of those
studies to a very different modality
which we have embraced more recently but
the person who pioneered this Wisconsin
at Columbia who really originally
developed those methods to study
Alzheimer's disease but he was
interested in cerebral blood volume
mapping rather than through blood flow
and he has shown very nicely in animal
models but also in human subjects that
the measurement of cbv seems to be a
better indicator of pervasive pathology
so for example a change in the firing
pattern of a particular brain region
that is not just in response to a
particular sensory stimulus but occurs
throughout the entire day in me will
last for weeks and months will lead to
changes in CVV for example at
Alzheimer's disease or mild cognitive
impairment decreased cbv actually
precedes the later onset of memory
deficits and the changes of hippocampal
volume he used the same methodology and
was able to show and this shown here and
you can see here the gray bar other
controls the patients are the darker
bars so you can see he a significantly
greater through the blood volume signal
in region C a1 but not in the deep teal
PFC and here it's in c1 indicated in
this heat map here in red but not at any
of the other hippocampal regions lastly
he showed that that increase in CB v and
c1 was correlated to the severity of the
psychotic symptoms in those patients so
there was the original evidence pointing
towards c1 specific hyperactivity in
psychosis and in the follow-up study
published two years ago they extended
this to Prague Romel subjects so this
shows you coronal sections through the
hippocampus this is anterior this is
still the uncas and this is the body and
then the tail of the hippocampus again
the heat maps show you in red increased
super blood volume and you can see when
this is plotted out as a bar graph that
only in the very end to your power of
the hippocampus do you get a significant
difference a greater cerebral blood
volume in those prodromal subjects that
convert into psychosis but not into
those
who do not convert into psychosis and
this increased through that volume
measured to him the prodromal period is
then related to volume change of the
hippocampus over a two-year period so in
addition to the original finding of
increased super blood volume also a
relationship between increased civil
blood wall and being a predictor of
later volume changes in chronic patients
so we have recently been able to
replicate this finding in chronic
patients so we did not study prodromal
or first-episode patients here so this
is the original study that we published
us recently and again find an increase
in ca10 blood volume not in any of the
other regions but I'm going to show you
not only that bar graph but I'm also
going to show you the scalloped well
they're not really the scatter plots but
gives you a little bit more of the idea
of the variance and you can appreciate
here that similar to Scott smalls paper
the cbv changes in Cu on in the
hippocampus are limited to the anterior
hippocampus in fact we had six sections
3 through the anterior three through the
posterior campus and in only one of
those three and two sections did we find
this dramatic difference there was a
similar difference also in the third but
only really in the anterior region do we
find this difference between
schizophrenia and controls not in any of
the other regions and lastly because CBD
is a difficult study to do it requires
you to inject a contrast agent Gallo
lynnium and so a lot of the patients are
not willing to do this we've also
explored other methodologies that allow
us to measure serial blood volume and
related phenomena this is the first and
that's dynamics except susceptibility
contrast MRI imaging in contrast to the
CBD mapping we can measure not only
civil blood volume but we can also
measure super blood flow in the same
person and by doing that using the same
cord where I just showed you the
differences in senior one you of course
can show the
in quiz cbv in the hippocampus but this
is in the context of normal CBF values
so bold signal changes would not pick up
on this difference in activity of the
hippocampus and the mean transit time
which is simply the ratio of the blood
volume over the blood flow is not
different either so that is important to
know because people have previously
shown that cerebral blood flow does
respond to medication and the increased
activity of the hippocampus as measured
with bold or Oh 15 pet normalizes with
the treatment with antipsychotic drugs
so an increased signal at baseline
without medication and the normalization
of that pattern with CBF with medication
we do not expect to see that with CB v
because those chronic patients were all
medicated okay so I'm coming to the end
of my little story about the hippocampus
and why people might want to look at the
hippocampus as one of the regions that
is affected in schizophrenia but I have
to give you one last piece of
information if there really are
hippocampal volume changes if the
circuitry is really impaired to the
degree that these pyramidal cells
whether they are in c1 or in other
regions are not properly inhibited by
local inhibitory neurons and if that
really leads to changes in blood flow or
blood volume as an indication of
activity would we really care
psychiatrist does this really lead to
any changes in behavior so we for many
years have been interested in memory so
while we have tried many times it's
actually very difficult to correlate
these abnormalities in CBF or cbv with
the memory performance of the individual
subject that would be great to do but
we've not been able to do so yet but in
different data sets we have shown very
convincingly that relational memory
performance we just linked to the
hippocampus is selectively impaired in
schizophrenia so I'm going to show you
only one of those paradigms this is the
one that was recommended by a group of
investigators
referred to as the Centrex initiative
they all came together and said if you
want to study hippocampal memory
function you want to take this paradigm
is called the associative inference
paradigm so the way how this goes just
imagine you are the person learning this
task in the initial training phase you
simply learn to associate one house with
one face and in different trials the
same house with a second phase and over
several minutes typically takes twenty
to thirty minutes for a subjects whether
they are healthy or have schizophrenia
to learn this association you will then
later on be tested to associate this
house and this face together in addition
to those house phase pairs there's a
second set of peers where you simply
have to associate two different phases
with each other
so literally in the instruction we say
just imagine this person lives in the
house and those two people are a couple
and then over time you learn this
association then during the testing
phase you make two different important
distinctions first since you have
learned this association you're simply
being asked to associate one of the two
phases with two of those and then you
select the correct one simply by
multiple choice and then you do
something novel you associate the two
phases that have previously been linked
to the same house with each other
so those phase pairs you've previously
already seen in the testing phase you
simply are being presented about 20
minutes later with the same phases again
and you have to recall them these peers
have never been shown together despite
the fact that these pairs have never
been shown together the accuracy in a
healthy subject is substantially greater
than in the simple recollection of the
previously seen phase phase peers that
is the associate inference benefit the
ability to benefit in your recall
accuracy based on the relational binding
of those two phases to the same
intervening item in this case the house
that is a significant difference which
is robust in healthy subjects and was
completely lacking in patients with
schizophrenia and more recently we have
shown that this effect
is already lacking in the very early
stages of psychosis on average those
first episode patients were ill for 12
weeks so they were called
schizophreniform patients and we
followed them also made sure that they
have converted into schizophrenia and
you can see that the non effective
psychosis patients lack disability this
relational memory ability but the non
effective first episode patients
typically go they would go on to a
diagnosis of bipolar disorder still have
the ability of this relational binding
so that's just one of the many different
experiments that we and others have done
that show very nicely that relational
memory deficits linked to the
hippocampus are more affected than
non-relational memory deficits
lastly we then proposed that these
changes in hippocampal function
hippocampal activity and hippocampal
volume evolve over time so just imagine
this is a time axis and this is when the
illness starts so this is the original
first episode of psychosis and then you
follow subjects for two years into the
illness so that they go through this
phase of schizophrenia form disorder and
ultimately go into schizophrenia so
based on our data in the villa Kulas
data and others we would hypothesize
that hippocampal volume is still within
the normal range at the beginning of the
illness and then decreases over time
over a two year period that the
functional memory memory deficits
already present in the non-effective
psychosis patients even with the
hippocampal still being normal I didn't
show you the data but in those where I
showed you the behavioral data the a
hippocampal memory was normal so that's
why make the hypothesis and last but not
least based on Scott Shaw Bolton Scott
smalls data that super blood volume as
an index of activity precedes the
changes in hippocampal volume so you
have three waves of pathology the first
one being increased activity as an index
of inter neuron dysfunction then within
a year or two a change in hippocampal
memory function and then within another
year or two a change in hippocampal
volume and only after all of those waves
have occurred do you see them the
full-fledged pathology of all three and
the chronic patients so I hope that that
was convincing to you that at least at
the level of post-mortem studies protein
and gene expression studies and
structural and functional neuroimaging
studies there is convincing evidence
that there's something wrong with the
hippocampus but have we really done
anything more than that have we really
done anything that links the hippocampus
to an understanding of the mechanisms of
the illness so of course I've not given
you tons of more information that I
could have provided for example that
there are distinctive genetic risk
factors that are actually translating
some of their pathology through the
hippocampus whether that's disc one on
regulan well that's the Alpha seven
nicotinic receptor many of those have
been linked as genetic risk factors to
an abnormal function of the hippocampus
I did not talk about that at all there's
also emerging evidence that
environmental stressors can convey some
of their mechanisms of illness via the
hippocampus to give rise to psychosis
whether that is ischemia or whether that
is poor nutrition or whether that's
infection I've also not giving you any
evidence that the hippocampus has
anything to do with the cardinal feature
of psychosis I've only given you
evidence that it's related to memory
deficits but that's my somewhat
conservative bias that I would like to
talk about the things that I know
something about that's why I heard that
story but there's quite a bit more from
other people that could flesh out the
store that yes there's something wrong
with the AP campus at various different
levels okay but now I go back to the
original theme of the talk so we have to
then ultimately Oscar says what can new
imaging for small research contribute to
a better understanding of psychiatric
disorders and how can they validate
clinical concepts all that we've really
done is we've given you some evidence
that there's something wrong in the
laboratory with hippocampus whether
that's the post-mortem studies I showed
you or whether it's the imaging and yes
maybe there's also some delimitation as
they call it from other disorders so
dissecting for example
affective psychosis from non-effective
psychosis that the hippocampus is
differentially affected in patients with
schizophrenia versus bipolar disorder
with psychotic features and there's
quite a bit of evidence that that can be
done so those are the two things we've
done but we have not given you much that
the clinical description the different
types of psychosis or schizophrenia have
something to do with pathology in
hippocampus we are just starting to
follow patients over time to actually
see how the pathology of they become
pers evolves over time all of the data
that I showed you so far are
cross-sectional studies except Scott
smalls one study which looked at
progression of illness over two years
and showed you an increased CVV in the
prodrome predicting volume change after
two years so in addition to that we also
then have to raise the bar even further
because in addition to Robins and gos
A's five validators again these are
considered the gold standard that makes
it a good psychiatric diagnosis there
are others and particularly the overall
functioning over time as a predictive
validator that met that is important for
clinicians and that ultimately will
determine the fate of a psychiatric
disorder if clinicians cannot predict
either response to treatment or ultimate
outcome of the disease it will be of
little value and we will not see the
community of clinicians or researchers
embrace a diagnostic manual like the DSM
if it cannot reach that point but again
going back to my research nobody has
shown that these changes in the p campus
which are robust with effect sizes of
point 5 point 6 i anyway will aid it to
the prediction of response to treatment
or outcome of patients so that gets me
back to crap allen's
paradigm and when I made the bold
statement that that's really where the
problem are I would like to go back to
this we have started with the notion
that a clinician can make a diagnosis of
let's say schizophrenia somebody else
can take a loop of brains and study them
in the laboratory
and do nice for small room studies and a
third page in the third group somewhere
else can collect genetic data and study
the genetic etiology of the same
construct schizophrenia we all believe
that we will end up at the end at the
same natural disease unit as capelin
called said philosophers would call it
natural kinds the idea really is that
different approaches to an illness are
ultimately converging on the same
natural units but it is unknown in fact
it is unlikely that those different
validators clinical features anatomy and
ideology truly converge on the same
entities that we can study in the clinic
or in the laboratory so the question
then is whether the paradigm that we
have chosen the crap a lenient paradigm
to believe that whether you're a
clinician an anatomist or geneticist we
will all at the end come together it's
almost like building a tunnel through
the Alps and somebody starts in Italy
somebody starts in Austria and you will
end up together in the same place but is
that really going to happen
we might just pursue different paths and
end up in very different places so how
would that then be tackled at the level
of psychiatric diagnosis that of course
has led some people to ask for a
revolution or at least a Copernican turn
so rather than describe you know
subscribing to the heliocentric view of
the world and replacing it via with a
geocentric or vice versa there are some
people who say let's throw out the
diagnosis let's not make that the center
of our universe let's start with a brain
and once we understand the brain and all
of its different satellites and all of
the different aspects of that universe
then we will understand mental illness
which of course is nothing but Calvin
Niki in 1906 arc Idris you got it all
wrong you have to first study the brain
and once you understood the brain then
you will be able to understand
psychiatric illness well well that might
be a good scientific agenda to pursue it
is clearly disconnected from the
clinical reality that we at this point
not knowing which of those different
universal models actually will be
the right one have to establish markers
of the disease to make a diagnosis to
actually implement treatment and in
psychiatry you also need to know that
these treatments often have legal and
forensic implications so these diagnoses
are not given simply because somebody is
eligible for benefit let's say take a
day off or have some disability benefits
these diagnoses have strong implications
for their functioning in society so we
need to do that at this point and we
cannot simply wait for that Copernican
turn to come from scientists at the end
also we need to better understand the
phenotype at the level of the individual
person schizophrenia often considered to
be the worst psychiatric illness does
not lead to an impairment in about 10 to
15 percent of patients once they have
gone through the active and acute phase
of the first episode of psychosis
meaning they will have a remission of
the illness and can return to a higher
level of functioning that at the core
destroys the principle of crapola know
that we have disease phenotypes that are
homogeneous so what are the things that
we need to do next in psychiatric
research and I'm giving you examples
here some infused by local flavors first
is that rather than doing
cross-sectional studies where we use
clinical trial designs or neuroimaging
cross-sectional studies we need to
combine those cross-sectional studies
with longitudinal more epidemiological
samples and really understand the
evolution of brain structure and
functional differences before the
illness emerges through the initial
stages and then ultimately at the end of
the disease we also need to spend much
more time to really understand the
first-person account of the mental
illness rather than the third-person
account of the clinician and we need to
then translate that to a much better
understanding of social function in
general and social dysfunction in
psychiatric patients and last but not
least of course you hope that there will
be some people out there somewhere in
the world
who make those connections between the
human studies that I other clinicians
would be engaged in and understandings
of the cellular and molecular mechanisms
and as examples I've given here one of
the large initiatives the enigma
initiative there are several others that
I could have chosen that have brought
together large new imaging data sets and
are now embarking on longitudinal
imaging studies which for psychiatry is
still new territory quite surprisingly
I've also included here
aleem sachs who should be a strong
reminder that having the diagnosis of
schizophrenia does not predict the fate
of this particular person because being
a patient with schizophrenia can still
make you possible to have a full
academic life and be a MacArthur Genius
award winner and last but not least I
don't have to tell you about the broad
and the initiative that is underway to
really understand more of the molecular
and cellular mechanisms so I think I
made it in less than an hour and also
for those who have known me over the
years they know that I started all of
this because Steve kept me at Mass
General for too long and then I started
here and then went to MacLaine and for
the last nine years I've been at
Vanderbilt thank you very much